hey I'm back and today we're gonna
answer the question what is the
healthiest country in the world can you
guess Japan okay let's talk about it so
Japan is one of the healthiest countries
for several reasons number one it has
the most super centenarians per capita
in the world in other words a super
centenarian is someone who lives to be
at least a hundred and ten years old and
then in the South Okinawa they have the
highest number of centenarians in the
world and those are people who live to
be a hundred
now Sardinia is up there as well
probably is tied with Okinawa as far as
the highest number of centenarians but
overall in Japan they have the lowest
rate of age-related diseases diabetes
cancer arthritis Alzheimer's also the
obesity rates are one of the lowest in
the world why well we're gonna get into
their diet but I do want to mention in
2009 the Japanese Ministry of Health
Labor and Welfare came up with something
called the Metabo law and it's
interesting to call it the Metabo law
and not the obesity law because anyone
who is actually between 47 years old and
74 years old is required to be measured
okay each year and for men it cannot
exceed 30 3.5 inches and for women it
cannot exceed 35 point 4 inches now I'm
not sure their penalties whether it's
through the insurance company that they
have or the government but I think it's
very motivating to have this as a target
because this is the indicator of insulin
resistance and the amount of insulin in
the body and if they can keep their
insulin low they're going to avoid
diabetes certain risk factors of getting
cancer arthritis for sure and
Alzheimer's which by the way is like
type 3 diabetes I also know that if you
exceed this you also have to have
certain classes to teach you what to eat
I don't know anything
about what's in those classes but I
think it would be great to have this in
the US and of course to teach them the
correct information on this would be
essential because the problem is the
government is usually stuck with the
bill paying for all the complications of
these things right there so they're
being very proactive so now let's talk
about what these Japanese actually eat a
lot of fish okay
raw fish and sushi with seaweed which
has all the trace minerals the fish and
the shellfish is loaded with DHA
minerals vitamins its nutrient dense and
high-quality protein the vegetables
especially sea vegetables they do a lot
of pickled vegetables and fermented
vegetables for the gut yes they do rice
and noodles but they also do green tea
some fruit and nado which is a fermented
soybean product which actually even
though it doesn't taste very good it's
loaded with vitamin k2 which is
essential and removing soft tissue
calcium from the arteries and the joints
this is also really good to support the
mitochondria and they also do a lot of
walking now if you haven't seen my
recent video on Sardinia I put a link
down below but there is some common
denominators between that part of Italy
and Japan they do consume fish and
shellfish and vegetables of course in
Italy they do more pasta than rice or
noodles and they definitely walk a lot
and also I think the thing that is the
icing on the cake no pun intended
would be this law right here which
forces people to focus on the correct
thing which is their waist size which is
a direct reflection of the amount of
insulin if you're new to my channel I
want you to learn about insulin
resistance watch the link below and
thanks for watching
hey if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos